all right then
just gonna wait for everyone to enter
the stream prior to
beginning
that has been hot
let's see if i can move this down just
slightly
the noise is back
can you hear me now
okay all good now the mic is very scary
i know
sorry
so
um we're just gonna wait for some people
to enter the chat prior to getting into
the reason for the stream
and also i have some very quick updates
prior to the main content so
good loud and clear
loud and clear
all right so let's see
who enters the stream we'll give it a
maybe a minute more or so
i know it's a little late well at least
it's late in my area
uh it's currently what time is it it's
almost nine o'clock p.m so
uh but
you know i decided to do a stream at
night because it's usually most quiet
during this time
so um
this video is going to be about some
general book recommendations since many
of you have been
requesting my
recommendations so i'll just give you
a brief examination of a brief and very
concise examination of my library
only a couple of books here um that i
have on hand and maybe we'll do some
more at a later point
but as of right now i think this will
suffice
for at least an hour long podcast or
more we'll see
oh goodness me it's too early in the uk
i do apologize
but i generally only get on podcast in
in the evening so
um afternoons are pretty rare for me
since i'm working most of the time but
uh other than that
oh no i did not i was working at the
time i do apologize i was not able to
see that podcast so
i don't want to waffle
uh
waffle
so uh quick updates
um videos are still coming obviously
they're doing very well um i've noticed
however that because of the quality of
the content that i'm producing and the
fact that i'm producing it by myself i'm
going to try to find ways in which to
[Music]
not necessarily shorten the content but
make the content
uh maybe spread it out a little bit
further so i don't have to pack
everything into one session
because lesson one is huge uh hopefully
the the subsequent lessons for the first
course of the and losing project
will go a lot more smoothly but right
now i'm noticing that the production
value because i set such a high standard
it's taking me a lot more time than i
wanted it to and but this new microphone
hopefully is going to help in terms of
audio production
um so look forward to that inshallah
also
i've recently purchased with your
assistants
a new desk to be utilized for a very
different perspective here i'm a little
bit
bored with this background
and it's very messy background and it's
just you know that background back there
is for my response videos in general
higher production quality videos
so but this this whole background my
office background is not exactly
enticing or very professional looking so
i've ordered another desk to be utilized
here excuse me
and what's going to essentially occur is
that i'm going to switch this
perspective around so that you actually
see the desk that i'm working at and you
know my window and my library and that
seems that's just a much nicer
perspective
right so for future content for future
podcasts
um
so expect that change very soon
inshallah
so let's get into it i guess
because that's all i really have to
update um and let's start with i don't
know
how about books on information literacy
shall we do that first
right just give you some book
recommendations
okay so the first one i want to
recommend is uh called know it all
society
uh truth and arrogance in political
culture by michael patrick lynch okay
and this book right here you can get
this on
amazon and i will put links in the info
box
whenever uh
this is uploaded so or published
right so know it all society it's very
interesting it primarily talks about
the american situation in american
circumstance when it comes to
understanding
ourselves and our place in the in
knowledge our place in society with
regards to our opinions and what is
considered fact and fiction
but however it's backed up by a lot of
good studies and it showcases that in
general the american population and
i would say even the global population
suffers from a form of arrogance when it
comes to their understanding of things
the culture that we currently have today
is full of individuals who without any
expertise whatsoever assume that they
know everything and it's like i said
it's backed by a number of case studies
uh it's very well written it's quite
concise it's not very long i would say
it's
if you don't include the notes at the
end you're talking about only 170 pages
but it's a worthwhile read and it gives
you a pretty good glimpse into the
mentality of most people today in that
they assume that truth and knowledge are
defined by a democratic society when in
fact they are not
um okay so that's number one
let's put that down
all right welcome
thank you
let's see here let's see what's another
one where is it okay this one's very
interesting it's called post truth by
lee mcintyre
this is an interesting book because it
talks about the same phenomenon with
today's culture in terms of it's mostly
focuses on fake news
and uh he argues that we live in a
post-truth age
and he includes a lot of anecdotes but
as well as a lot of studies
with respect to how people sort of just
are not only more gullible but why
they're more gullible and with the
reason why they reject facts okay for
more convenient conspiracies and things
like that and it's a really good book i
have the receipt in it for some reason i
don't know why
i guess that was my bookmark uh yeah so
i went through it and i was actually
thinking of using this for the course i
may still do so i believe i even quoted
at some point but it's a very well
written book um it's not very long
either it's quite concise you're talking
about 160
i don't know 170 pages almost the same
size as the last one uh so this is a is
a pretty good book very small as well
nice to have and it was written uh it's
been published by mit
so it's a it's a pretty it's a pretty
good book
i recommend this highly
oh by the way some of the books that i
show you are not necessarily the authors
aren't necessarily like pro-islam or
anything like that but a lot of the
information they provide they're in is
pretty good
okay so
another one that i think is really good
and this was a finalist for the pulitzer
prize
written by nicholas carr
and uh i really like this book a lot
because it goes into more the scientific
studies regarding uh what
technology is doing to our brains from a
neurological standpoint
okay and uh this book is called what the
internet is doing to our brains well
actually it's called the shallows what
the internet is doing to our brains
it's got a number of awards and it's a
really good book in terms basically it
shows us like
what
what's the difference between reading a
book a physical copy and reading it on a
screen and there's actual in actuality
there are a number of studies that
showcase that
our focus and our comprehension actually
suffers as a result of reading things
online versus reading them in a book the
same content
so it's a really fascinating read i
truly recommend this
especially for those of you who want to
take a more technological more
scientific approach towards or
neurological approach towards
understanding
uh why people uh don't don't digest
information that well online
this is a very good book the shallows
okay so truly recommend this
for everyone
all right
everyone's still here
i don't see anyone typing so
all right then so in the next one i
think for information literacy that i
would recommend
is uh
one that i think you've heard me uh talk
about quite a bit
actually
it's called the death of expertise the
campaign against established knowledge
and why it matters written by tom
nichols somebody who i respect as well
in terms of their knowledge on the
subject matter and he goes over the
cultural phenomena
and it's very similar to the know-it-all
society but he goes over the cultural
phenomena of rejecting expertise a
global phenomenon of this he goes over a
number of studies and anecdotes as well
uh it's also not a very big book it's
it's almost roughly
230 pages more more than that 240 pages
uh but it's very good talks about the
the
lack of intellectualism in contemporary
society
and why people reject expertise and why
people think themselves to be experts
and it gives you a better understanding
into the mentality
of a lot of the culture that we have
today and i think this is probably the
best book in explaining especially
how young muslims are approaching islam
and how they think of themselves because
as you can tell we have a lot of young
muslims online who who think they know
more than scholars both from the liberal
and the conservative camp
and that's causing a great deal of
problems in our society so essentially
it's a book that uh goes over the
dunning-kruger effect
okay so i think it's a very good book
right
all right then so that was uh
that was information literacy amazing
right
um let's go over let's take a quick
break here
how do i
take a quick break how do i remember
the information i read well first off
you have to be interested in what you're
reading
and secondly if i have to reread
something i will and i take my time
reading books i don't like to rush
through things unless i'm doing like
unless i just need to be reminded of you
know something or
or i'm doing like a really quick
research paper and i already know what
i'm looking for
but generally i like to take my time
with books so
writing notes is good some people do
better writing notes okay so
let's take a quick break from the dry
stuff right the dry
things that we don't uh that we don't
like to read right and let's go look at
fiction and i only got like one fiction
book here but i really enjoy this book a
lot and this book is very personal for
me because um
my professor my philosophy professor
when i graduated from my undergraduate
studies
um he gave this to me as a gift
okay we were actually quite close
and he considered me to be one of his
best students and
maybe not academically but he considered
to be one of the brighter students i was
not around as much as i wanted to be in
school because i had to work full-time
but
he gave this to me because he believed
that i would benefit from this
tremendously and that it would touch my
soul as he described it and he knew that
i was always interested in like
existentialism and stuff and we didn't
really learn that much about
existentialism during undergraduate
years it was mostly analytical
philosophy so he gave this to me and he
said that he enjoyed this immensely and
this is a nobel prize winning book okay
and it's one it's by one of my favorite
authors and since reading this i've read
i've tried to read some of his other
works as well
and uh his name is kazuo ishiguro yes
he's japanese but he writes in fictions
about european society and this is the
book is called remains of the day
and i kid you not and i'm not trying to
be less manly here anything like that
aside from the quran
this is the only book that ever made me
cry
and i'm not going to ruin it for you but
the book
is about the angst the existential angst
of a butler who has lived his entire
life as a butler who followed in his
father's footsteps and discusses his
understanding of love and death in life
and it's it's such an intimate and what
i mean by intimate such a personal
journey of this man you almost feel like
you're in his shoes that when he cries
you feel the need to do so as well it is
that wonderfully written and i recommend
this for anyone i believe there is a
movie but i suggest reading the book
okay the movie did not touch me as much
as the book and he is a phenomenal
writer
amazing writer okay
um so that's what i would say amazing
book and if you enjoy this and you can
read some of his other works as well
okay but it's also profound it's also
profound in the sense that it forces you
to think about a lot of things in life
so
um yeah
yep
let's put that down okay so
all right then let's see if we got some
now we got some more dry stuff right
philosophy yeah philosophy
okay i got a lot of those books here
okay i got some religion ones too we'll
get to those at the end
yeah we'll get those at the end all
right
okay
here we go
here we go here we go
uh you guys have been hearing about me
talk about analytical philosophy from
time to time um i also have books on
other types of philosophy like
continental philosophy and stuff but
we're going to avoid those for right now
but i think the best
concise guide to the history of
analytical philosophy if you really want
to understand the background of it and
kind of where i got
my you know sort of
i think it summarizes my thoughts about
the history as well i'm in general
agreement with with the way that this
has been presented
um but uh written by stephen schwartz
okay philosopher stephen schwartz it's
very simple uh title a brief history of
analytical philosophy from russell to
rawls
uh very good discusses the very
beginning of
of uh analytical philosophy um
even the logical positivists it talks
about the war between the pragmatists
and the logical positivists uh it also
talks about witchenstein and all these
other people
uh it's a very fascinating read it's got
a lot of good illustrations and
anecdotes
and i think that you would really enjoy
this
okay
i got this one from singapore so i don't
know if the one that you find online
will be from the same publisher
or have the same you know
cover but this is generally a very good
read um and it has it's very well
written and it's good for the layman so
i suggest this book right here
okay
let's put that down yeah
all right
you've heard me mention this book on
many occasions
um
and you're probably not going to be
surprised by it but this is for anyone
who wants to understand science
it is the first place you need to start
beyond
anything else and this is considered to
me to be the bible of philosophy of
philosophy of science okay
i use the term bible loosely but what i
mean by that is that if i were to take a
couple of books if i could only take a
few books with me
to a deserted island this would be one
of them
and
this book is written by thomas kuhn now
this is a third edition i do have the
fourth edition somewhere i can't find it
and uh he did write a post script as
well which was published after his death
but this is
the structure of scientific revolutions
probably one of the driest books you'll
ever read in your life but it has it
opens your mind
it opens your mind not just about
science but but about the world when i
first read this book it literally
changed my mind about almost everything
okay
this book is amazing
he's not perfect by any means but this
is this is an intellectual revolution
okay
and i will tell you anyone who reads
this book who's never heard of it not
even understands the material has never
seen the material before it will change
your mind it will it will shift your
perspective it will make a paradigm
shift as uh thomas kuhn would say
this is one of the most revolutionary
books ever written in philosophy
okay and it was his only real book that
he wrote in terms of philosophy so
you need to read this
okay um
and i i promise you you will end up
agreeing with the vast majority of it
um
it's an excellent primer on how science
is conducted and how it changes he goes
over a number of historical examples um
it's very realistic in its approach it's
an amazing amazing read okay and uh i i
often read this more than once
so
just for its insights and when i need to
be reminded of certain things amazing
book really influenced the way that i
think and the reality is that here's the
irony of this i didn't learn this i
didn't read this start reading this book
until my master's degree in malaysia and
it was a muslim professor who gave this
to me
who made this one of our textbooks okay
so that's that's the other irony it's
funny when people say well muslims are
against philosophy and thinking and
things like no
i i this is this is during my graduate
education that i read this okay so um
amazing book amazing book um please read
this
okay day
let's see
i believe that's the second edition that
you showed me and i have the third
edition there but i think there's a
fourth edition so
i have read edward fesser's book yes
it's a good primer as well but i don't
have it on me so
oh gosh what else do we do we have here
to read a lot of philosophy books okay
this is a more recent title uh by isaiah
dean sarder another muslim philosopher
it's called post-normal times and he has
a theory about the time period that
we're in the types of thinking that we
have uh basically he argues that we're
in a transitionary phase in human
history and that he tries to explain why
people's understanding of truth and
knowledge and things like this have sort
of like
become weird that's the best way to go
the best way to explain it
and it's a very
lovely book i haven't written i haven't
excuse me i haven't read all of it yet
there's a number of articles in here but
he discusses this postmar post normal
phase
of life and how to sort of navigate it
and i'm getting a lot of great insights
from it so
i might discuss this in more detail when
i'm done with it but in the meantime i
recommend this book it's very insightful
and very interesting
and it's from one of the only muslim
philosophers in existence today so
that's another reason you probably want
to pick it up uh yeah lovely book um
right so okay let's go into something
else here another i got two more
philosophy books and we'll be done
um something i've been reading recently
as well the existential survival guide
um not the best primer and
existentialism that i've read um i think
i recommended a book before and i don't
have it on me because i think i let
somebody borrow it and they never gave
it back which is why i don't let people
borrow my books very often and i'm going
to purchase it again so i'll discuss
that book at a later point but i think
this is this is good so far uh it's more
historical than anything but
interesting take on existentialism
discusses the existentialist thinkers
what they were thinking why they were
thinking them and how it ties into their
biographies on a very you know a very
deep level so he goes over so she goes
over the views of kierkegaard and others
and uh it is recommended it and for
those of you know what existentialism
existentialism is it discusses human
experience with things like death and
freedom and authenticity and things like
that
and uh the author also gives a really
interesting personal biography about how
existentialism sort of saved them from
themselves
and how they were like a drug addict and
things like this and how reading
existential philosophy kind of get them
got them out of that so it says somewhat
of a religious overtone though it's not
a religious book by any means and he
doesn't i don't think he subscribes to
existentialism in a religious sense but
it gives a sense of like personal
journey um through philosophy and i
think it's an interesting book i think
it's worth reading so if you want to get
kind of a taste of existentialism okay
it's not as deep as the ones that i used
to read but uh the authentic self and
all that stuff but i think it's a good
book
all right then let's go over something
else here
last but not least
the
magnum opus of the greatest muslim
philosopher in the contemporary period
the prologue to the metaphysics of islam
and exposition of the fundamental
elements of the world view of islam by
side muhammad naqib
my teacher
as well as the teacher of my teachers
okay
i have one of the last remaining copies
of this book because they no longer
publish it in its original form
and in fact this is such an old book
that it was signed
that it got a
there's an autograph in here
uh
from my school in 1996.
okay
uh
it was gifted to somebody else
and i actually got this copy later on
okay so um that's how old this
this this particular copy is
this is a wonderful primer on philosophy
islamic philosophy
from the perspective of somebody who
considers considers themselves a
neo-gazalen
okay so this is the this is where you're
going to find the peak of side muhammad
naqibalatas is thinking all right
um
yes this live will be saved so
um i do sorry i'm feeling a little bit
cotton-mouthed here so let me take some
tea
when i talk too much that happens
so
la la la
okay that's better so um yeah wonderful
book um you can find this pdf online for
free
but if you could ever get a hold of one
of these copies it might be very
difficult for you because um
yeah they're like 200 or something
online
remaining copies left
that's how much they typically are
um so it's called the prologuemena to
the metaphysics of islam
an exposition of the fundamental
elements of the worldview of islam and
it's a wonderful read goes over the
concept of adeb
and what metaphysics is and and how
modern philosophy is different from
islamic philosophy et cetera et cetera
it talks about islamic ethics it talks
about the essence of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
his attributes etc from a philosophical
lens or an islamic philosophical lens
um
to be frank with you
not all of
muhammad keeps our tosses thinking is my
own i've diverged from from his modes of
thought in some areas however this is a
very beneficial book regardless and it
shows you the depth and richness of our
tradition when it comes to philosophy
and uh rational thinking so
highly recommended this is this is a
magnum opus it's not respected enough
okay
here we go
next
uh this is not really a philosophy book
per se but i kind of included it because
i enjoyed
his take on things um
so when the new atheists were still a
thing right
this really quirky sort of marxist
thinker by the name of terry eagleton
came out against dawkins and harris
and um
i didn't think much of it at the time
but uh when i read it it was actually
probably one of the most brilliant books
i've ever read now he he defends
christianity primarily through this book
but his his
his style and his tone
influenced me tremendously uh not
necessarily his arguments though they
were pretty good but his style and tone
the way he kind of makes little jabs and
stuff like that
amazing if you read this you'll get more
intelligent so terry eagleton reason
faith and revolutions reflections on the
god debate this is a really
fun book to read in fact it's actually
quite humorous i i enjoyed this
tremendously and sometimes i read over
it again just get a laugh
but he really takes down dawkins and
harris like they're nobody um they are
nobodies but like it's just it's
hilarious and this was at the height of
the debate
and unfortunately not many people picked
up on it because he kind of wrote it a
little later than some of the other
people who refuted them but
and um he wasn't as well known i guess
in terms of the debate but i think that
his book did the best job of sort of
like
pulling the rug from under them so
um
yeah
so yeah i really i really think this is
a good one to have as well okay if you
can still find it i i'm sure it's online
i will try to post a link
okay so yeah
all right so what's next i got a lot of
books lying around let's see what's on
this table over here oh right then uh
yeah okay so religious books
yale
yeah just so the salafis
i don't like calling them salafis but
you know just so the really super
conservative people don't
claim that i'm a heretic i have to do
this right just kidding no no this is
this is just for your own benefit
but uh yeah maybe this will save me two
from getting criticized too much right
reading it's haram
right okay so anyways uh let's look
through some of these and i think this
will be really good for you
it was a joke
i don't consider those people salafis
real salafi is are really intelligent
people
who have uh who have a very nuanced
understanding of things
the fake selfies the the people online
who just like to bash people all day i
don't consider them salafis right they
consider themselves a salafi sir
okay
so let's look at this um
obviously the quran yes that is a book
recommendation but i don't think i need
to recommend that to muslims so
um here we go uh
the best surah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
would be the noble life of the prophet
by dr ali muhammad al salabi
okay
for me this was the best it's a three
parts one i only took volume one here
but this is the best one because he goes
into the most detail out of everyone now
i'm i like academic reading so i don't
mind all those details if you're looking
for something more like a novel
this would probably not be not the best
bet but for historical background and
stuff he does the best okay this is the
best
um book that i've ever read in terms of
getting all the details
okay and at least in in english sealed
nectar is great a little bit more
concise this one goes into tremendous
amount of detail like you like it goes
into every background of everyone
surrounding the prophet sallallahu
alaiha
you know in the context of of every
single event
and you know why things happen et cetera
et cetera so
wonderful wonderful book
um great deal of
knowledge in here okay
um
i'm sure there's a problem with it
there's a problem with every book but
you know
for me that was the most beneficial
okay so let's see what's next
sealed nectar is more concise this one
goes into tremendous amount more detail
so you get a larger picture of what was
going on
okay
now
so
some of you may be asking why i'm an
athari
um well uh i have a number of reasons
but i think that uh sheikh hataman hajj
who is a personal
um
who i look up to as a scholar
i think he made a very concise book
recently this is recently published as
of last year i believe so last year was
it 2021
was it last year no it's 20 20 yeah last
year
and uh it didn't give much attention but
i read through it and i think it's
probably the best most concise guide to
understanding what authorism is
why what it means to be an athlete how
we think
and it shows that we're actually quite
rational
so um
as opposed to what many ashari and
mathuris think no offense to them
at all um
so yeah and this book is called between
the god of the prophets and the god of
the philosophers reflections of an
authority on the divine attributes by
hatham al-hajj
it's a wonderful book i recommend
purchasing it immediately
yes the stream will be uploaded
so
okay so recommended it discusses allah's
attributes and how
muslims who are athari
see
things different from philosophers and
why philosophers are wrong et cetera
it's like i said it's quite concise but
i think it's very well written gives you
a very good introduction and it's a good
primer so
interesting
okay
next
also translated by sheikh hatham al-hajj
this is good for tasa wolf
from a humbly perspective i'm not humbly
or maliki but
i find a lot of benefit from this book
and you can find this stuff online too
but stations of the travelers
um by sheikh ali salaam al-harawi
is a very good book on tussle wolf i
think that
you should get this so
yeah that's also a very good book on
and those are all my book
recommendations for today
i recently purchased this book excuse me
by uh sheikh abdul hakim murad and i
haven't read it yet so i'll give you
some a review of that probably a later
point
it's traveling home i heard it's very
good so
we'll see
yeah
and uh that's about it
that's all my book recommendations
and that was only 30 minutes long i'm
sorry
so i will link these in the information
box when when this uh after this after
this video is published